foreign
[Music]
I hate getting high on flights because
when I do I fall asleep and wake up and
start saying some dumb [__] like
gentlemen it's been on a fly with you
oh it's been an honor flying with you
you know what I've never had that in
Flight I've always had the fantasy I've
never had that in-flight experience like
I've never met anyone on a flight
neither have I neither have I I've never
exchanged like convos and be like you're
banging let's talk
we're both going the same way you're not
stopping off anywhere else yeah we're
stuck here I always used to have those
moments about like I wonder if I'm going
to see a Ting on there and we're both
like
we're both reading books and we're both
the only one awake on the plane actually
there's a spare seat next to me she's
like can I sit down and I'm like
I mean you can yeah you can you're gonna
have to be quiet though but I'm scared
you can't be yeah
I don't know what's gonna happen bro I'm
tempted and she whips the blanket on our
laps that I can't handle yeah yeah
before the before the rugs
before it lands
she'll be perplexed
[Laughter]
[Applause]
before the technology
and it just landed on a solid two there
just pitching a tent she'll say what a
[__] should be confused it will ruin the
whole meat Cube why is that everyone's
waking up
she wake everyone Up In First Class
everyone about petrified I'd roll over
to like I'm falling asleep I'd roll over
bro close my eyes as soon as she screams
I'd roll over and close my eyes
you're not screaming at me so I'm waking
up just like everyone else
waking up just like everyone else I'm
startled what's going on I'm pressing
you when you press the T what's going on
I'm confused this white woman's
screaming at me what's going on
who are you I didn't know she was here
um all the same you turn over your belt
buckles disheveled
I'm like this try to fix it bam oh my
God that's hilarious I said I'll wake up
with everyone else
facts
[Laughter]
thanks bro oh
Jesus Christ
right I'll also never forget when I
worked in JD Sports as an Xmas temp in
Leicester
this wannabe team leader chased the
nitty out to store over a 15 pound pack
of socks only to get punched in the
mouth and lost the front tooth he was
told he could search for it on his
50-minute lunch break
nah bro on his 15 minute lunch break
first of all 15 minute lunch break is
illegal facts that's illegal anything
goes in Leicester
facts anything does go with that stuff
would know yeah yeah 15 minutes 15
minutes facts they made me eat on jobs
let me standing up yeah
so maybe he's standing up yeah so what
man tried to Catch a Thief
the thief bombed him in his mouth lost
his tooth and the manager said well
obviously you're not looking for it now
get some tissue on your break you can
find your team I'm not paying yourself
for you too because no one asks you to
chase this Mickey are you security [__]
I used security yes do your job stay
within your program next stop check
stocks that's what I asked you to do now
I've got to fill out forms I've got to
spend my 15 minutes lunch filling out
fast
don't be a hero bro
facts bro oh those jokes
I was walking towards my car and I heard
someone started raining insults saying
[__] idiot Park like a wanker I had
to walk past my car I couldn't take the
shade
I would do the same thing do you know
who that was oh tolly sweat
[__] idiot part like a wanker wow I
know I can't I need to see her face in
that moment she'll be disheveled fragile
would drop I could see her eyes yeah wow
I know she was just step imagine you're
trying to get into a car so I keep on
keep on keep on keep on keep on
hilarious hilarious [__] idiot part
like a wanker
huh that came from the pool yeah I will
walk straight past my car facts facts
um uh why am I at CVS and I hear this
guy in front of me ask for 50 condoms so
I looked at my home girl and we burst
out laughing why does this man turn
around look dead at us and say make it
52.
no
I'm scared
you mean he's about to [__] off too
r-a-p-e straight up I made it 52.
so
bro
bro I would be looking for cameras
because this this can't be real [__] me
this cannot be real oh he's asking for
50 condoms that's specific that's a
rapist I'm telling you a specific
and then you just hear like okay 52.
they will stop laughing like that
immediately that's literally went like
you know with the um
when you've got a conductor and he goes
like and everyone's stung the violin
goes
that is that moment
went
rotted make it 52. bro scary bars if I'm
if I was in that c visual hit my basket
dropped oh if I overheard that you'll
hit my basket the Till's everywhere
there's coins everywhere bro I'm not
serving them anymore oh wow I'm pressing
that alarm
immediately that's hilarious too that's
terrifying I hate it when [__] my age
don't cheat you're not gonna marry that
dude so stop being childish
swear facts
facts it technically is facts that's
that's like them that's the Muny times
and you're like what are we doing I'm
here I'm right here right now and you're
on it yeah you're so obviously on it
it's so big that it's annoying facts Bro
[__] Your Man yeah and [__] me do you
know what I mean
it's easy oh they're so jokes you ever
take a nap so good that you thought you
missed the school bus but it's Sunday
and you're 32.
bro yes I have that's all I have to say
today yes I fax that's hilarious wow
Sunday North 32. that's hilarious I've
woken up not know where the [__] I am I
have done that so many times not even
like wake up after a night like a full
night's sleep I wake up at like 2 3 A.M
yeah yeah where am I yeah because you
know when it sleeps deep and you just
wake up oh facts bro where am I I've
done and you're but I've woken up and
not know where I am so much that and
also been like especially like a hotel
I've been so confused that like I'll
wake up
realize that I'm not at home but also
still be so certain that I am at home
yeah I think I'm upside down
because my wall isn't here
I think I'm upside down yeah yeah yeah
and shoot up bro facts and then once it
all comes back to you you're like you
got yeah you just kind of just like
slide yeah
what the [__] was that yeah what the
[__] was that yeah literally what the
[__] was that it's so jarring oh
pre-workout needed just think of him
with other girls
[__] now bro hilarious yeah sometimes
when I wanna when I wanna be when I want
to move like I'm 15 again the thought of
the love of your life with previous
partners that will send you crazy
I'm sending you crazy yeah it would yeah
yeah it sounded crazy like on a logical
conversation it's like oh shut up yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but if you
actually accept the role yeah yeah
you're like wow moaning yeah you moan
for him wow three years before you met
me you moaned for man come on yeah yeah
so you start thinking of insults oh fam
you're delusional when you're right what
do you mean United before before next
time I made you not that's impossible
not my wife not my wife not my wife who
who
are right now you don't want to be
married literally this is what you're
telling me you're a jezebel you're a
hauler yeah yeah and I can't associate
myself with you wow never I made you not
not my wife you don't love me at all
period Point Blank
yeah oh Jesus that's funny um I've got
one more go on
bro you finish uni and it's just one
problem after another quote tweet since
I switched from pencil to Biro I've not
rested
laughs
bro that's hilarious from Pennsylvania
five yeah 100 100 the days of the pencil
was so easy the days of the pencil was
so stage one bro he's mad when you had
your own little maths book that you'll
just open with the Donny with the yeah
um what's it called Q oh it's called
like QPR or something yeah CPR CPR
something do you know what I'm talking
about you know there's white maps and
English books used to get literacy
numeracy books and there's a white books
yeah
sunglasses on I don't remember yeah yeah
on a computer
you probably did have a Mac prick yeah
yeah facts way before your time and
teacher would just be like oh do page
seven
and the arithmetic was easy all right
pencil team just back again oh and then
yeah you'd have
you would have English and they'll just
say write a poem about fireworks night
or something and you're like this is
piss bro fax all in pencil everything
was easy everything
[Music]